Moebius truck what hey I got [ __ ] up
that's what happened what the [ __ ] day
is this this is like really far into the
future this should be last chapter
though
[ __ ] a so much [ __ ] water how far
am I probably to go and kill Frank now
never liked Frank lazy piece of [ __ ]
he's just a lazy piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
solar panel did maybe [ __ ] this
okay let me give a howl these thick rich
real quick see what's going on over here
[ __ ] it hack at it
[Music]
you know that big pile of rubble okay
[ __ ] pond trees and [ __ ] this is like
[ __ ] deer 2111 2111 day at 2111 okay
at Birds or no chase and that's what she
said
okay so my guess is I gotta clean up
that solar panel with this cloth and
bring it back to life
[Music]
come on
planet
[Music]
well I had a wet it
well this is like yellow show me around
[ __ ] walking simulator if I can walk
in simulator that's a rag glass out long
can anyone tell me
and I said why like a tampon let's do
this now you shouldn't wait like a
tampon
you know if you really need to loop
something the best thing is tampons
really
[Music]
you know our wives powering [ __ ] don't
play stupid he's gonna hate all I must
be six-foot-something Wow hey hey you
got the black lung an elastic at that so
it's that bad John
machete what the [ __ ]
get to a thicker is there I gotta call
some more about our coffee
[Music]
it's dull machete with thick roots
records oh my god you've gotta be
[ __ ] kidding me
I knew I sent a song so [ __ ] him oh
that slap a rock I'll do it just walking
back and forth she's missing our us
taillight production
this ain't no rusty Lake production Wow
I bet it's that bench
[Music]
oh if I double-click he runs oh my god
this the best thing I ever heard
hello Frank I know you bay here Frank
Joe what are you I'll get you some water
that [ __ ] run now that now you can
run [ __ ] only took like the whole
game [ __ ] around
get some water [ __ ] [ __ ] water
that's a [ __ ] walking simulator era
[ __ ]
tell me what's going on before it dump
it in the flames here you go Frank ten
what's going on I don't understand
I am I had no time I pushed it as far as
did it go could be I don't get it do I
really meet what look I've got no reason
to tell you but I guess the truth is is
so big agent Joe Frankie come on Joe I'm
an undercover agent deployed by the
Kremlin Mike job I what the [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] my real name is Yuri
buddy chef and I came to America in my
early 20s
oh it just hasn't worked here spent
nearly ten years building the foundation
of an ordinary life but the truth is
that my life is far from ordinary I'm a
spy I was planted by the Soviet foreign
intelligence agency to gather intel on
advanced US military research programs
by 1968 I had run out of goodwill with
my handlers at the Kremlin
desperate for something anything to
report
if the buyer turned out to be a
government show having convinced my
superiors that I was on to something I
got a job as a janitor
so if she did quit what tell me quit
right
my hunch was correct but I didn't have
the full picture not yet for a while I
thought they were onto me feeding me
both is impermeable time was running out
Brezhnev in your President Nixon said an
nxn he I caught a sec [ __ ] it I was
tailing an engineer into an off-limits
lab when I bumped into Barney from
secure knowing I wouldn't get another
chance or stole security patches snuck
back in like just fun but then it
clicked not only could I steal the
technology it was the perfect getaway
yes separate batch listen Joe I'm really
sick I'm not making the time machine as
a timer like a toaster it's designed to
return home unless I have no idea how
you got here and I guess it doesn't
matter grant you [ __ ] arrest it and
I'm gonna start coffin all right yeah
guess there's the second time machine
[Music]
it's got a betcha no honey [ __ ] died
places Burgin frame
so we gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
well
foreign organisms detected the four
needs I'm the one who's good
I must've bet you just kind of crackle
Tanner freeze yourself up
now shake it right here just when I find
I had a [ __ ] run
[Music]
gotta fries myself better phrase my
sperm get the [ __ ] that [ __ ] lady in
fact everyone with your [ __ ] flow
alright get in there come on come on I
got Isaac man it's [ __ ] all down here
all right JJ good game
talking Wasserman woken up in the future
you get these pens
[ __ ] am I
[Music]
solitary
I'm two threes in here
[Music]
I'm either one of these a lot fade out
though okay
it's cameras spin next to me whoa there
here baby what this paper [ __ ]
running in he lock him up he's
african-american that's so messed up
[Music]
see funny extra hey danyetta a man
here's some paper the key to salvation
right it took away my tools your heads
Hey oh they fear me
okay I got it I use this for the TV get
the guy to be distracted get the crotch
use a knock over the pens get the pens
of the paper and get back to this guy
[ __ ] simple this is a ticket amateur
all right here you know no I can't go
there yet
he's gonna give me the combo bra all
right boys out there
need paper to mightier than the sword
bringing hope I know the [ __ ] sand
but it's above my pay grade it's above
my pay grade miss I'm sorry dr. Brown
whoa whoa how do you feel fine and as
soon as what in 30 years well sure I
know it's 2012 and like the others you
were placed in an article god oh that's
well that's true you did all have some
kind of flu actually in any case the
pathogen was largely dormant due to the
extended hype so it's yes I'm afraid you
don't know much about all of that
all I know is that the company who the
remaining assets were sold off we've
been helping rehabilitate cryo forms
clients for the past five years
unfortunately cryogenics was a little
apparently a lot of archons original
documentation was destroyed in a fire
sadly the others haven't been quite as
coherent they share certain delusions
you know end of the world you however
seem so yes Joe quite sure so
tofox happening
I can just leave now
so are we all ready but yes don't worry
the rehab teams eager to help speaking
of I happen to catch you on the
surveillance I perfect I'll be well [ __ ]
is that later the ending not a shitty
game honey oh I don't like it as much
it's alright
look at me freaking rich have I got
iPads iPhones quartz oh I found this
barbaric mm-hmm nine ten seven days very
sad
[Music]
yeah it's a coda or something or a
telecommunications thing guys are my
beard big Eric
yes good like the art style the boys
acting I think think I don't know I
think was just a theme that got me
pressing that's alright it's a rugged
game and dot thought that or is that is
it gonna say or is it I can't tell ya
okay thanks for watching yeah yeah